He is revered as one of the greatest artists
of all time.
For centuries he has typified the perfect
artistic genius.
His greatest legacy is the surviving works
that we can see today - The Sistene Chapel,
the Statue of david, the Pieta.
Yet, behind the artworks lies a complex and
stubborn man.
In this week’s Biographics, we go beyond
the facade to discover the real Michelangelo.
Early Days
Italy in the 15th century was very different
to the country we know today.
Back then it was a collection of small republics.
These city states were all under the governorship
of the Pope in Rome.
The key republics were Florence, Genoa and
Venice.
Every state had its own governors, nobles,
peasants, priests and government officials.
Nestled in the remote Apennine Mountains of
central Italy was the small village of Caprese.
It was here, on March 6th, 1475, that Francesca
di Neri Buonarroti gace birth to her second
son, Michelangelo.
Her husband, Lodovico di Leonardo Buonarroti
Simoni was a lowly official who had the job
of convicting and sentencing criminals.
When baby Michelangelo was sixth months old,
the family of four moved to Florence.
Here Lodovico bought a small farm near the
village of Settignano.
It was in this village that the child spent
his early years, under the care of a wet nurse.
Farming off newborns to a wet nurse for the
first two years of life was a common practice
at that time.
The woman who took in Michelangelo was married
to a stonecutter.
In later years, when he had transformed himself
into a sculptor, Michelangelo commented that
he had drunk marble dust with his nurse’s
milk.
When he was three, Michelangelo returned to
live with his family in Florence.
The family was poor and, with new babies arriving
frequently, the household was overcrowded.
Lodovico received a meagre government salary
and his farm was not very successful.
In fact, he believed that the work of a lowly
farmer was beneath him.
When he was six years of age, young Michelangelo's
tough life got even tougher.
His mother died, leaving behind five young
sons, including a newborn.
Lodovico did his best, working two jobs and
still managing to trundle the boys off to
Mass at the church of Santa Croce in Florence
every Sunday.This church was filled with magnificent
works of art, including a crucifix carved
by the famous sculptor Donatello and wall
paintings by Giotto, one of the greatest artists
of all time.
The young Michelangelo must have marvelled
at these magnificent pieces.
In 1485, Lodovico took on a new wife.
Lucrezia degli Ubaldini Gagliano came from
a rich family, bringing 600 florin to the
union as a dowry.
This was an enormous amount at that time and
it flipped the fortunes of the family overnight.
An immediate result of the family's newfound
wealth was that Lodovico was able to afford
to send Michelangelo to a Latin school to
learn reading, writing, and mathematics.
But the boy soon proved that he was no academic.
Bored with his lessons, he would stare out
the window while doodling on paper.
However, he did fall in love with poetry.
A Passion for Art
Returning home for vacation, Michelangelo
told his father that he was more interested
in art than in academic studies.
But Lodovico was not impressed.
At that time artists were the lowly paid servant
of noblemen, being considered little more
than a servant.
Lodovico wanted his son to aspire to more
than that.
The only person who seemed to understand Michelangelo’s
passion for art was an older boy he had befriended
by the name of Francesco Granacci.
Francesco was himself a budding artist, apprenticed
to the famous artist Domenico Ghirlandaio.
He took Michelangelo to his master’s workshop
and showed hm works in progress.
The younger boy was mesmerized by what he
saw.
He knew that this was his destiny.
Despite his father’s negativity, Michelangelo
kept begging to be allowed to pursue his passion.
Meanwhile, his friend Francesco encouraged
him to produce some drawings, which he showed
to his master, Ghirlandaio.
The great artist was impressed and expressed
the desire to also take Michelangelo on as
an apprentice.
Finally Lodovico relented, and at the age
of 12, his son became apprenticed to Ghirlandaio.
The master ran the most successful artists
workshop in Florence, along with his two brothers.
They were kept busy decorating churches in
Florence.
The brothers had a number of apprentices,
aged between 8 and 15, who lived with them
and assisted with paintings and murals.
The parents, including Lodovico, had to pay
for living expenses and training.
From the Ghirlandaio brothers, young Michelangelo
learned how to prepare a wooden panel for
painting and how to plaster a wall in preparation
for the painting of a fresco.
He was also taught how to make working drawings,
called cartoons, which would form the basis
of finished paintings.
The Prideful Apprentice
Among the apprentices, Michelangelo was an
immediate standout.
Still he proved to be stubborn, and quite
full of himself.
He was given the task of copying works previously
drawn by his master and, having done so, declared
that his works were better than the originals.Ghirlandaio
acknowledged that the boy had great talent,
but he was angered by his prideful attitude.
He also saw that Michelangelo lacked the patience
needed to learn some of the skills required,
such as painting frescoes.
He showed little interest in grinding and
mixing paints and couldn't be bothered mixing
the ingredients needed for the smooth plaster
needed for fresco painting.
When he was 14, Michelangelo went one step
too far.
He had copied some drawings that his master
had done of women.
But then he dared to ‘correct’ some finer
aspects of the originals by going over them
with a broad-nibbed pen.
This was too much.
Ghirlandaio kicked Michelangelo out of the
workshop, claiming that there was no teaching
this ‘know-it-all.’
Rather than being discouraged, the talented
teen made the decision that paint and plaster
were not for him.
He considered them to be a lesser form of
art.
To him the real skill lay in stone, producing
fine sculptors of the human form.
This desire would take him to the very pinnacle
of Florentine nobility the house of Medici.
The House of Medici
Before Michelangelo had been dismissed by
Ghirlandaio, some members of the ruling Medici
family visited the workshop.
Among them was an elderly sculptor named Bertoldo
di Giovanni.
This man noticed the talent that Michelangelo
possessed, and he struck up a relationship
with the boy.
After his dismissal, the budding young sculptor
sought out the older man.
Bertoldo was employed by Lorenzo de’ Medici,
the most powerful man in the city, to make
statues and medals and to look after his art
collection.
Many of Lorenzo’s statues were displayed
in a garden where artist went to draw and
carve.
This area was a gathering place for student
sculptors, who would get feedback and instruction
from Bertoldo about their work.
Soon, Michelangelo was a regular in the garden.
The now fifteen year old began creating sculptures
from clay and bringing them to the garden.
Though he was younger than the other budding
sculptors, his skin was clearly beyond theirs.
This led to jealousy.
Some times this led to physical violence.
In one encounter, Michelangelo had his nose
broken.
But the boy was not deterred.
Begging a piece of marble from another sculptor
he created his first relief carving - the
head of a faun.
Just as he had been hoping, this sculpture
was seen by Lorenzo Medici, who was immediately
taken with the boy’s skill.
He brought Michelangelo into his fold, giving
him his own room and paying him an allowance.
The young artist’s life was now more peaceful.
He was able to settle down to the task of
perfecting his chosen artform.
One of his first major projects was to carve
a scene from mythology on marble as a relief
panel - the battle of the centaurs.
These creatures with the heads and arms of
men and bodies of horses gave him plenty of
scope to show action and form.
The realism and gentle precision of this work
is remarkable for a sculptor of such a young
age.
The other major piece that Michelangelo produced
while working in the House of medici was a
relief panel called Madonna of the Steps.
It shows the virgin Mary nursing the infant
Jesus.
The piece is carved on fine white marble and
shows the Madonna’s face in profile, as
she holds her infant son against her.
Things were going remarkably well for the
17 year old.
He was living in the inner sanctum of the
richest family in the city and he had a powerful
patron who admired his talent.
Unfortunately, it wasn’t to last.
In April, 1492, Lorenzo suddenly died.
His son, Pierro took over, but he cared little
for sculpture.
He gave, Michelangelo no work until the winter,
when he decided that he would like a snowman
made.
He ordered Michangelo to make one.
It would prove to be the artist’s strangest
commission.
Around this same time, the prior of Santo
Spirito asked the young sculptor to make a
crucifix for his church.
Delighted with the result, the prior give
Michelangelo the use of a room in which he
could work.
Here he was able to dissect corpses in order
to study anatomy.
In order to make the most life-like sculptures
of the human body, he believed that he had
to know how it was put together.
Thus, he became one of the first people to
dissect and study the human body in this way.
A New Patron
By 1494, Florence was facing a crisis.
An army led by King Charles VIII of France
as at the walls threatening to overrun the
city.
Many people, including Michelangelo, fled
the city.
He traveled to Bologna in northern Italy,
and then on to Venice, an important trading
city.
Here Michelangelo hoped to find work.
However, he could not find any employment,
so he went back to Bologna.
Having lost his old patron, Michelangelo set
out in search of a replacement.
He found it in the form of Gianfrancesco Aldrovandi,
a local noble and politician.
Aldrovandi set his talented new sculptor to
the task of carving the missing figures at
the unfinished shrine of San Domenico in the
church of the same name.
Again Michelangelo, now twenty, had fallen
on his feet.
He enjoyed a comfortable home, had stone and
supplies provided and received commissions
for his artwork.
Just as had happened in Florence, this bred
resentment among other sculptors.
They paid rent, bought tools and stone, and
survived out of their own pockets.
Return to Florence
Meanwhile, back in Florence, a change of power
had occurred.
A priest by the name of Girolamo Savonarola
had instigated a fierce campaign against the
House of Medici.
When the threat of French invasion had emerged,
the House of Medici had fled the city, leaving
Savonarola free to take power.
This strict churchman disapproved of paintings
and sculptors that showed the naked human
body.
As a result, prospects were not good for local
sculptors.
However, in 1495, Michelangelo felt a great
urge to return to Florence to see his family.
While there, he made contact with some members
of the House of Medici, now living under false
names.
One of them.
Lorenzo di Pierfrancesco de’ Medici wanted
Michelangelo to help him sell a statue that
he had made earlier.
It was a figure of the Roman god of love,
Cupid.
If the statue was aged to look like an ancient
statue, Lorenzo reasoned, it would make a
lot of money in Rome.
Michelangelo smeared the statue with dirt
to make it look as if it had been buried.
He then took the forged antique to Rome where
it was purchased by a senior churchman, Cardinal
Riario.
While in Rome, Michelangelo was introduced
to some powerful people, including members
of the Borgia family, who numbered among them
the Pope.
Cardinal Riario, who was well aware that Michelangelo
was really the creator of Cupid, quickly commissioned
him to create another statue for his collection.
The statue that resulted has come to be regarded
as Michelangelo's first masterpiece - the
statue of Bacchus, the Greek god of wine and
celebrations.
Yet, although everyone else was impressed,
the cardinal was not.
He thought the god looked too drunk and refused
to pay for the work.
Michelangelo now had to fight to get paid
for a job he had already completed.
On top of this, he received news that his
father had fallen into bad financial straits.
What he needed, and fast, was a new patron
to support not just himself, but also his
family.
The Pieta
For several months, nothing seemed to pan
out for the 21 year-old master sculptor.
He was without a patron,he was without payment
for his Bacchus statue and his father was
in desperate need of financial assistance.
Then, In November of 1497 things took a turn
for the better.
He was commissioned to produce an exciting
new work by a French Ambassador by the name
of Cardinal Jean Bilheres de Lagraulas.
The Cardinal envisioned a statue of the Virgin
Mary cradling the dead Jesus, a subject known
as the pieta.
It took Michelangelo two years to complete
the Pieta - but it was worth it.
The finished work was displayed in the Vatican
and everyone who saw it was amazed at the
realism of the flesh and fabric that the sculptor
had fashioned from cold marble.
The Pieta made Michelangelo famous.
Now, the most powerful men in Europe were
clamoring to have him do work for them.
It seemed as if his money woes were well and
truly behind him.
Artist to the Pope
Back in Florence, the scene had changed once
again, Savonarola, the priest, had fallen
into disfavor and been executed.
It was now safe for artists to return and
pursue projects there.
The authorities of the Florentine cathedral
began to formulate the idea to commission
a giant statue of the Biblical killer of Goliath,
young David.
Two sculptors had already been commissioned
to do the job.
Both had failed, merely managing to make the
huge block of marble almost unusable.
In 1501, the job was given to Michelangelo.
In order to do the job, the sculptor had to
stop working on another job in Rome and relocate
to Florence.
This flitting from one project to another
became a common practice, and one that frequently
created legal ramifications.
The creation of David was an immensely challenging
and lengthy job.
The first decision was to choose a pose that
fitted in with the way the marble had already
been worked.
This prevented him from emulating the traditional
pose, which showed David standing with Goliath’s
head at his feet.
So, he decided to depict David in the moments
before the fight as he were looking upon his
foe.
His next move was to surround the huge marble
with barricades.
The he went to work.
He tirelessly chipped away at the giant.
Three years later, the statue of David was
completed.
It was a triumph, with crowds lavishing rich
praise on the creator of the 14-foot nude
figure.
The man who had commissioned the work, Piero
Soderini, ruler of Florence, was also impressed
- but he told Michelangelo that David’s
nose was too broad.
The sculptor’s stubborn pride now come to
the fore.
But it was tempered with common sense.
Taking a handful of marble dust, he climbed
up the scaffolding and pretended to chisel
the nose.
He then let the dust fall to the ground.
Soderini declared that the nose was now much
better.
Sistine Chapel
In 1503, a new pope, Julius II was elected
in Rome.
Julius had great artistic ambitions, and he
knew who he wanted to spearhead the many projects
he had in mind.
Only Italy's greatest sculptor, Michelangelo,
had the skills needed to do justice to the
great theocratic works that the pope envisioned.
Julius knocked down the unstable fifth-century
Basilica of St. Peter’s in the Vatican and
began rebuilding the church on a much grander
scale.
The centerpiece was to be his own tomb, which
would be designed and carved by Michelangelo.
This massive project was intended to show
the greatness of Julius as both a pope and
a patron of the arts.
It was to be three storeys high and covered
in life-sized sculptures.
The sculptor spent the first eight months
just quarrying the marble need for the project.
It would prove to be his most frustrating
project, one on which he would work, on and
off, for the next 40 years.
In the end the finished tomb was smaller than
planned, but still vast.
Only three of the statues were by Michelangelo
- the large, bearded Moses, and the Biblical
characters Rachel and Leah.
And, instead of being placed in St. Peter’s,
it was put in the much less grand church of
San Pietro.
Four years into the tomb project, Pope Julius
set his sights on the ceiling of the Sistine
Chapel in the Vatican.
The ceiling was painted with a pattern of
gold stars but the Pope envisioned something
far grander.
Even though Michelangelo was known as a sculptor
and not a painter, the Pope chose him to do
the work.
The great sculptor had not worked on a fresco
since his days as an apprentice back in Florence.
But when the pope chose you to a job, you
did it.
But that didn’t mean that you had to it
willingly.
Michelangelo considered himself to be a slave
to the whims of the Pope.
He wrote about the painting project . . .
This is not my profession.
I am wasting my time, and all for nothing,
may God help me!
It was a massive job.
The chapel's ceiling covered a curved surface
of about 5,600 square feet (507 square meters).
In Addition, the ceiling had an uneven surface
- and it was 60 feet above the chapel’s
floor.
The Pope commissioned the artist to fill this
canvas with scenes from the Old Testament.
Michelangelo planned out nine scenes taken
from the book of Genesis.
The centerpiece would be the creation of Adam.
For four pains-staking years, Michelangelo
worked on the ceiling.
It was back-breaking work.
The figures were designed to be seen from
the floor, but the artist had to paint high
up on scaffolding, lying on his back.
According to his official biographer, Condivi,
he worked on his own, applying the plaster,
mixing the colors and doing all the painting.
The results were breathtaking.
The use of perspective and the dramatic rendition
of the figures were admired by everyone who
saw it.
Having triumphantly completed the Sistine
Chapel project, Michelangelo returned to his
work on the tomb of Julius.
Wen Pope Julius died in 1513, the urgency
went out of the project.
In 1517, the new Pope, Leo X, asked Michelangelo
to design a new facade for the church of San
Lorenzo in Florence.
Though he had no experience as an architect,
the sculptor was confident that he could do
a good job.
He threw himself into the project, buying
a piece of land near the church in order to
work on his facade.
But, then, in 1520, the project was put on
hold and then cancelled all together.
Michelangelo was furious.
He had invested himself fully, both physically
and financially into the project.
Partly to placate him, the Pope gave him a
replacement project - the Medici Tombs, to
be created in remembrance of two members of
the family who had died prematurely.
Michelangelo began work on the Medical Chapel
in 1519, to which was added a library a few
years later.
Both buildings took years to complete and
are stunning designs.
Crisis
The artist was now at the height of his creative
powers.
But crisis was just around the corner.
In 1527, armies from France and the Holy Roman
Empire invaded Italy.
Rome was looted and burned.
By now there was yet another pope, Clement
VII and he sided with the holy roman Empire
when it besieged Florence.
A loyal Florentine, Michelangelo returned
home to help defend his city.
He set to work designing new fortifications
to help protect the city.
But his efforts were in vain.
After a long struggle, the city fell, with
many people being killed.
Michelangelo went into hiding, concealing
himself in a tiny crypt under the altar in
the Medici Chapel in San Lorenzo.
There he stayed until news came through that
the Pope had no animosity against him.
The Waning Years
Michelangelo spent his latter years writing
poetry and continuing to work for the popes
in Rome.
One of his most famous poems describes how
uncomfortable he was when painting the Sistine
Chapel ceiling, bent almost double, with paint
splashing on his face.
As he aged, he wrote more poems of a religious
nature.
Throughout the reigns of several Popes, he
held the position of chief architect at St.
Peters.
Meanwhile he worked on carvings that were
variations of the work that had first propelled
him to fame, the Pieta.
It was while working on one of his Pietas
on February 12th, 1564 that he began to feel
feverish.
He took to his bed, and despite the efforts
of his doctors, died six days later.
His dying wish was to have his body be returned
to Florence - the city
that he loved.